as the trailer to Star Trek Nemesis once
said for every force in the universe
there is an
opposite kind of funny to reference that
movie in a video about the top 10 worst
of the year but that is to say when I
make a top 10 best movies of the year
list I got to make a top 10 worst movies
of the year list it's funny as time has
gone on I feel like the the concept of
making a top 10 worst list has become
taboo like you're not supposed to but as
the great philosopher Erman trout once
set yeah
well I enjoy it so sit back relax pour a
beverage water or otherwise let's
celebrate the top 10 worst movies of
2023 funny enough there's a movie I'm
actually going to Omit from this list
cuz I I went in pretty hard on Five
Nights at Freddy's in my review but as I
say comment below let me know plot twist
I do read the comments in my videos
feedback is important I saw a lot of
comments that were like yeah the movie
was messed messy but the games are messy
and that's what the movie was supposed
to be to me it sounds like a bit of cope
doesn't change the fact that it seems
like Five Nights at Freddy's the movie
did land with fans of the franchise in
large part anyway and in a world where a
lot of these big studios or movies uh
betray the properties when a movie does
right by fans I feel like that should be
celebrate so live long and prosper Five
Nights at Freddy's I will see you in the
sequel also in a world where it was
tough for me to make the top 10 best
list to find 10 movies that I like that
much this was difficult in a much
different way I had to whittle it down
in a world where there about 15 bangers
that could have been on this list so not
having to deal with one more that that's
that's the thing I'm doing for myself as
well full transparency also these are
not reviews for the movies I'm just
going to briefly touch on why they're
bad I do have reviews of all of these
movies if you want to check out the
reviews let's not stand on ceremony
let's get this bus fire going with
number 10 number
10 I'm just going to start this out with
Ant-Man in the WASP Quantum Mania a
movie when I watched I was like all
right there was some enjoyable things in
it maybe with a bit of booze it didn't
make it better by the way so I was just
wrong about that that rating just seems
very flawed once again another MCU movie
that has cameos I feel like cheap sitcom
cameos boiling it all down it's just you
had something that worked with the first
Ant-Man movie and they just it's like
they forgot all about it the movie is
too big for ant-man's britches it's as
simple as that compounding with the fact
this is actually what made it on the
list is I continually forget about modok
being in this movie it's so strange I'll
see a movie I'll talk about it with
friends and they'll be like better or
worse than Ant-Man of the was Quant
Mania and I'll be like it's probably
worse and their response is always is
there anything in that movie that's
worse than modok and I'm always like oh
my God I forgot about modok no the
answer is no it's the worst thing in a
comic book movie in 2023 how does my
brain just pull it out and forget about
it it's like Horus slug horn sorcery or
some [__] I always forget about modok
and then I remember modok in the movie's
just worse you know what was better than
this movie and modok the Flash number
nine next up Aquaman and
the lost kingdom yeah don't worry after
this I never have to try to remember the
title of this movie again Aquaman 2 is
actually kind of an interesting thing
that's lived in my head for about a week
I do not believe the movie saw in
theaters was the movie James Juan made
or set out to make I feel like Aquaman 2
to James Juan is alien3 to David Fincher
if you believe the reports that's
exactly what it sounds like this movie
was supposed to be well something
cohesive something that made sense but
the Final Cut of the movie just jumps
around it I splashed my scotch on me
waste not the Final Cut of the movie
felt like Edward Scissor Hands got his
hands on it or something just sliced it
to [__] I just feel like we've seen
enough good from James Juan to know that
this is not how he does it if this is
the last movie in your DCU before the
reboot I don't know why you just don't
let the guy make the movie he's set out
to make none of it's going to lead to
anything anyway so just let it happen
number eight next up is a Megalodon part
two you know what I me yeah the first
Meg you say oh it's just dumb fun this
Meg movie was just dumb bad Dollar Store
Leviathan Dollar Store Abyss though I am
glad to know 20,000 Fe below the surface
without a suit all you need to do to
keep from being crushed from the water
pressure is clear your sinuses I get
campy fun for the sake of Camp be fun
but you got to lean into it more than
this movie did it wasn't fun it was just
trash number seven next up the MCU
strikes again with the Marvels how
someone who has the power to reignite a
dying Sun by flying through it would
struggle in any fist fight whatsoever
well less Beyond me but she is
struggling against the most forgettable
villain in MCU history so there's that
this movie was a mess bad CGI bad green
screen cheesy SNL comedy bits about cats
slurping people up and vomiting them out
for the sake of getting them off a space
station or a planet of people who sing I
feel like when a documentary is made
about the movies of this time some years
or decades from now looking back we're
going to learn the truth about how much
AI played a role in writing this [__]
tell them we just got to call it how it
is which is why these lists are
important number six speaking of AI
possibly and probably making trash let's
talk about wish wish the chat GPT
screenwriting test run known as generic
a fantasy Adventure I think me talking
about AI writing this [__] is my way of
trying to believe that people didn't
write it they can't be that lazy right
no way an entire Act of Bruce Almighty
that illustrates granting everyone's
wish is probably irresponsible went over
a human being's head the cinematography
was boring there was no sense of art to
it it didn't feel like fantasy the side
friend characters were forgettable it
felt like they had a movie and someone
was like well we need a group of side
friend characters 2023 was a year that
Disney felt the squeeze we need to try
crazy concept people have been telling
them that for years but now they know
financially it's wild to see the
contrast between Disney Animation when
they were in their Prime in their Heyday
to now to this number five next up The
Exorcist believer which could have been
pretty cool in fact when the movie was
starting out I was like all right it's
going a different direction feels like
they're trying to flesh this out give it
a shot turns out it was one of the most
generic [__] Exorcist movies I've
ever seen in my life which is what I'm
talking about when I say disappointment
generic Exorcist movies Diamond dozen
and a generic Exorcist movie is a sequel
to The
Exorcist dude also has Ellen buron in it
dude it was when they made her useless
that's when the movie truly knows dive
for me I was like okay she's in this
movie to have her in the trailer to get
asses in the seats number four next up
retribution do you remember retribution
I didn't until I was looking through my
reviews of the year coming up with my
top 10 list and I was like what was that
wow well that sounds bad for what I was
saying about it after my review I did
remember it somewhat I remember it being
nonsensical illogical ass [__]
physics jumps the shark like a
[__] at one point good for Li n
and still getting those paychecks still
riding the wave from the first Taken
movie that's impressive but this is one
of those straight to Walmart bin movies
I don't know how it got a theatrical
release but there I was sitting in a
theater number three next up Children of
the Corn barely remember this one either
however it was a weird thing that was
always there on my mind like like a
little Post-it note when people would
come up to me I'd run into people at
theaters it's like one of the it's one
of the questions people like asking me
what's the worst movie of the year and
usually I'm not good at that I'm not
used to being like Oh hey here the top
five or the I'm just I usually have my
mind on other things so I would have to
whip out my phone and be like all right
let me go through my reviews and see
what I've reviewed this year not with
Children of the Corn Children of the
Corn was always there I always had that
to pull from and i' would always be like
well Children of the Corn sucked ass I
would it was just my go-to answer I
always knew it I always remembered it
and then a CGI corn monster when in the
book it's implied to be Randall flag
possibly but that would have been kind
of cool I didn't need to see a corn
monster just have something in there
that could be Randall flag intrigued me
a little bit less would have been more
but no sure CGI corn Monster by the end
why not who doesn't love that number
two man the top two it's the difference
between bad and and disappointing I'm
opting for disappointing being number
one so number two Expendables four feels
like forever since I saw this movie
turns out it was about 3 months ago wild
sometimes time flies sometimes it just
drags but Expendables 4 it was truly
awful what was once a celebration of the
action stars of yester year became a
cartoon version of itself again there's
leaning into cheese for the sake of fun
for the sake of the celebration of
action films and then there's just a
massive waste of time this is that
second one there's been some bad green
screen in 2023 a lot of which are on
this list Expendables 4 had the worst of
it holy [__] it DS on me two Jason
Statham movies on this list to be fair
Jason Stam does feel like the one
carrying this movie he's the one not
sleepwalking to the end when you have
martial arts Legends like e wise and
Tony jaw this in an action movie and you
waste them and the action is still this
bad no it's terrible number
one number one and I will say right now
is this objectively the worst well
that's subjective my brother and I have
a tradition at this point we will pick a
movie that's bad usually it's I have to
determine the movie cuz I'm the guy who
watches the movie so it's me double
dipping on [__] but we'll watch the
bad movie will talk [__] while sipping
Scotch already been decided Indiana
Jones in the dial of d
is the next movie in that tradition this
movie had a lot going for it man James
mangled was directing he's one of the
best directors working right now in my
opinion Harrison Ford was back in the
end they just brought Indiana Jones back
to make him this sad old broken grumpy
man on this
adventure well they Han soloed him like
I said in my review maybe it was a
spoiler Talk video but I guess that's
what you do with Harrison Ford
characters now have this great iconic
Rog likee Adventure bring him back make
him a grumpy old broken man whose life
has just Fallen apart and then [__] him
more again with that documentary in the
year 2035 looking back at movies of this
era I want to know the story behind this
never saw Phoebe Waller Bridge before
saw her in this
movie her character was an [__] when
anyone has to self-describe themselves
pump themselves up to other people
result daring beautiful self-sufficient
these movies are written by people who
apparently think Gaston from Beauty and
the Beast is likable cuz that's how he
would talk about himself that's right
Belle I'm resourceful daring beautiful
self-sufficient the chase sequences felt
too sterile too clean everything was too
CGI it didn't feel daring didn't feel
like Indie every other Indiana Jones
movie is better than dial of destiny
that includes Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull and that's why it's the number one
disappointment of 2023 thus to me it's
the worst of 2023 so there they are
there there you have it those are the 10
movies in 2023 that turned me into a
grumpy dick thank you for watching this
video I appreciate it and once again
like I said in my previous video thank
you once again for making another year
of Me on YouTube possible we press
forward to 2024 which let's be honest is
probably going to be a trash fire that's
election year dude out there it's going
to get ugly in here we just talk movies
and that's fun so your list of the top
10 worst or disappointing movies of 2023
whatever they whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see
[Music]
more